[Music]
what's your name CYO sweet I'm Mr Miller
I'm assuming that you got one of these
before I read the whole list well
there's 12 books on that list B
har good what is an
adult I'm
18 languishing in the Wilds of nowhere
Tennessee break this curse don't you get
scared walking through those woods I'm
the scariest thing in
[Applause]
there could
speech I want you to write a short story
in the style of your favorite author are
you offering me special treatment Mr
Mill well
uh John here is prepping her to be his
Transcendent is she pretty oh she's
talented damn even worse
what are you bring about I'm un inspired
I've had no achievement make him love
you
I'll she's open her mouth to say
[Music]
something but the words fell
away why did you write this this is
inappropriate right what you know is
what you said if you don't me R this
I'll have to fail
you I'm dare
you it's like he's been living in Gray
scale and you're the first thing he's
ever seen in
color you are the adult show some
responsibility you're my student and I'm
your teacher that's
all if she can convince them that
something happened between us I could
lose my job it's not all you could
lose you're going to ruin his life burn
it down it down it
down in your own words how did it start
said I was a good
[Music]
kid